hello and welcome everyone to the Active
Inference Institute this is active guest
stream number 41.1 on April 25th 2023
we're here with Elliot Murphy and
Stephen piantadosi this is going to be
quite a discussion we will begin with
opening statements from Stephen and
Elliot Elliott will then lead with some
questions and we'll have an open
discussion at the end so Steven please
thank you for joining and to your
opening statement
cool hi so I'm Steve piantadosi I'm a
professor in Psychology and Neuroscience
at UC Berkeley
um and uh I guess part of the reason
that we're here is that I recently wrote
a paper on large language models um in
part trying to convey some enthusiasm
about
um what they've kind of accomplished in
terms of learning syntax and and
semantics
um and in part pointing out I think that
these models really change how how we
should think about language
um how we should think about theories of
of linguistic representation and and uh
theories of grammar
um and likely also theories of learning
hello
awesome yeah so I'm Elliot meffee I'm a
postdoc in the department of
neurosurgery at UT Health in Texas
um I read Steven's paper with great
interest I did a lot of people and there
were some areas of convergence but the
the things I want to kind of focus on
today in responding to Stephen and kind
of probing off to do with areas of
Divergence maybe
um so you know Steven's paper is based
on the idea that modern machine learning
has subverted and bypassed the entire
theoretical framework of chomsky's
approach so I wanted to kind of respond
to some of these main arguments and some
other related arguments in the
literature uh that's some folks
listening might have some some insight
and thoughts on so it's a very common
criticism to say that large language
models just predict the next token and
which
there's obviously a bit of a cliche
right it's um not quite true and they
don't just predict the next token they
also seem to confabulate they seem to
hallucinate they maybe lie they randomly
provide different answers to the same
question and they seem to have
stochastically mimic language-like
structures they sometimes correct
themselves sometimes when they shouldn't
if you push them a little they kind of
change their mind sometimes
um in fact if Fox News is currently
looking for a replacement for Tucker
Carlson they could do less they could
definitely do worse than using
between if they're looking for a you
know similar caliber so these models
seem to do all sorts of like wild things
um and over the past 10 years there's
been a sequence of different you know
systems developed like we're tobacco bed
and each of them is based on a different
neural net approach But ultimately they
all seem to take words and characterize
them by lists of uh hundreds or
thousands of numbers so the G23 network
has 175 billion weights and 96 attention
heads in its architecture and as far as
what I know maybe Steven can can correct
me here we don't really have a great
idea of what these different parts
really mean it just seems to kind of
work that way like attention heads and
gpt3 can pay attention to much earlier
tokens in the string in order to help
them predict the next token but the
whole architecture from start to finish
is kind of engineering based motivations
um
and I always kind of wonder what about
all the models that kind of failed from
these llms from the different tech
companies it's like these companies
often seem to
um you know make it seem like they have
these models that really work very well
Straight Out of the Box
um and they all seem to be named after
some kind of famous artists right right
they have Darley after salad or Dali
they have Da Vinci maybe pretty soon one
of these companies will release a large
language model uh called Jesus or
something I don't know
um but they always say this here's our
New Foundation model it's called Picasso
it's the first one we tried it we're
just great no problems straight out of
the box but I always wonder what about
Oliver Black boxes that have kind of
failed every time there doesn't seem to
be a kind of a very open and clear
structure to the kind of scientific
reasoning behind selecting you know one
model or another uh but again I might be
I'm open to be corrected about that
um so even basic language models do
pretty well on
um like basic web prediction so the
issue is whether these tools provide an
insights into like traditional
psycholinguistic Notions like grammar
and passing so this is really why I kind
of prefer the 10 Focus model rather
language model uh suggested by people
like cyberveras
so it's been pointed out that no one
really thinks llms tell us anything
profound about python when they land
python code just as well as natural
language well python is a symbolic
language with a phrase structure grammar
and nobody says llms are unveiling the
secrets of python right so just to put
various here he says if a n models can
be construed as explanatory theories for
natural language based on their
successes on language tasks then in the
absence of counter arguments they should
be good explanatory theories for
computer language as well uh therefore
successful a n models of natural
language cannot be used as evidence
against generative phrase structure of
Amazon language
so Corpus model is really a more
appropriate term for other reasons too
people like Emily bender and some others
have shown that features of the training
Corpus in fact I think Stephen cites
this you cite this in your paper
actually as a limitation
um they show that features of the
training Corpus can heavily influence
the laying process so it's been shown
that the performance of large language
models on language classes is really
heavily influenced by the the diversity
of the training Corpus
um but natural language itself is not
biased right it's just
it's a computational system human beings
can be biased in what they say and how
they act and but natural language itself
isn't biased right so large language
models therefore it seems difficult for
me to you know agree that they are being
subject to all sorts of biases they
therefore can't really be models of
language they're models of something
else so just to kind of wrap up this
argument
um you know even though llms are clearly
exposed to vastly more linguistic
experience in children again this is
something else that Stephen can see it
and talks about in his paper and even so
their learning outcomes may still be
relevant in addressing what grammatical
generalizations are learnable in
principle so I do agree with this
statement here you know that in
principle they can tell us something
about learnability rather than things
like you know broad Acquisitions
Frameworks and but that's about as much
I think you can maybe say right now
showing that some inductive biases
um are not necessary for learning is not
really the same thing as showing that it
isn't present in children so there's
been a long debate about whether you
know negative evidence and instruction
and correction and feedback during
language learning are necessary or even
useful for infants and children
um but right now I kind of agree more
with Eugene Choi and Gary Marcus and
others who've highlighted how llms are
currently you know very expensive to
train
that clearly an example of a
concentrated private power in the hands
of a few tech companies their
environmental impact is massive
um and you know many people have been
less constrained and conservative in
their assessment here
um which much less other than Gary
Marcus and Eugene so Bill Gates recently
wrote that chat GPT is
um the biggest Tech development since
the uh graphical user interface the GUI
um and Henry Kissinger wrote in February
in the Wall Street Journal that as chat
gbt's capacity has become broader they
will redefine human knowledge accelerate
changes in the fabric of our reality and
reorganize politics and Society
generative AI is published to generate
new forms of human consciousness so very
radical claims happening at the moment I
do wonder if sometimes
or the AI hype may have you know saved
into certain portions of Academia
potentially a lot of grand plans being
made but I think you know more
concretely just to put it back to Steven
here I wanted to maybe raise the issue
of um there's a critique by rorski and
Beaumont that I I think he's read um on
lingbuzz
um
I think you saw on Twitter that you
don't like the response they gave
because the objection that they made is
that you know science is an example of
deductive logic your objection is that
science isn't deductive it's inductive
right and but I think the general Point
might be more accurate namely that you
can't you can't use the fact that
language models do well predicting some
linguistic behavior in humans and some
neural Imaging responses you can't use
that alone to claim that they can yield
a theory of human language
so in your paper Stephen you know that
it seems that certain structures work
better than others the right attentional
mechanism is important prediction is
important semantic representations are
important and therefore we can glean
currently based on these models right
um but so far that's really all I've
been able to glean in the literature I'm
not sure if you have more insights here
so Rosky and Boomer used the example of
poor prediction but strong explanation
right explanatory power and not
predictive accuracy forms the basis of
modern science and I want to explore
this a little bit later maybe
um but modern language models can
accurately model parts of human language
but they can also perform very well on
Impossible languages and unnatural
structures that humans can't learn and
have a great difficulty processing and I
know you're familiar with these with
these criticisms right
um but you're definitely not alone here
at the same time so uh Elia
um the chief scientist at open AI he
said in an interview recently that what
does it mean to predict the next token
well enough it means that you understand
the underlying reality that led to the
creation of that token
which is quite Divergent from a lot of
more conservative claims in the
literature here
um and also you know I would just say in
response to that that different
components of science can be either
inductive or deductive right it's not
really in either or you have an existing
Theory you formulate hyper hypothesis
you collect data you analyze it and
that's kind of deductive a deductive
process but there's also cases where you
start with a specific observation you
find some patterns and you induce
General conclusions right and then
there's abduction where you magically
invent hypotheses and and reduce the
hypothesis space you wouldn't really say
that deductive reasoning is unscientific
or inductive reasoning is unscientific
or abductive reasoning is unscientific
right these are all just different ways
of doing stuff
um I mean in your paper you give the
examples of using models to predict uh
hurricanes and pandemics as being
examples of stuff that is as rigorous as
science gets and then you implore your
reader to conclude that the situation is
no different for language models
um but I guess for me the issue is
models predicting hurricanes are not in
the business of answering the question
what is the hurricane
right models accurately predicting the
weather are very accurate but they're
not you know they're aligned with the
meteorology department but they're not a
substitute for it
um so I guess I'll just you know hand
that over to you
yeah okay well uh there's a lot there
um I I guess I could could start just by
saying that
um uh I agree with like many of these
criticisms right about uh these these
models being controlled by uh you know
one or two companies
um that being very very problematic
um uh you know they have all kinds of
biases that they've acquired because
they're trained on text from the
internet
um that's hugely problematic
um you know I I certainly agree that
there's uh things at least at present
that the models don't do well right so
um I think it's it's easy to to find
examples of you know questions and and
problems that will trip them up
um I I think why I've been excited about
them though
um is not uh not necessarily in in those
terms right but in in terms of
performance on language
um specifically syntax and and semantics
um I think they're uh far beyond kind of
any other other theory in any other
domain right so there's there's no other
Theory out of linguistics or computer
science which can generate you know long
coherent uh grammatical uh passages of
of text
um and so kind of admitting all of their
problems as uh you know tools or or
things which are deployed by companies
um um there's still this this question
of like how are they uh at dealing with
language and
um I think this is where a lot of the
enthusiasm comes from is there really
hasn't been anything uh even remotely
like them in terms of linguistic ability
um and that's the thing that that I
think is is exciting so yes I I agree
with with a bunch of these things you
you started with
um uh but nonetheless like I think in
terms of syntax and and semantics
there's just no other Theory which is is
comparable to them
um
but so let me let me push that back then
right so yeah I I would the the main
objection from a lot of people I've
spoken to in Departments of linguistics
who are like a lot of the general you
know first of your paper is to really
say well
um you know you're right they do they do
a wonderful job uh accurately modeling
all aspects of a lot of aspects of
syntax and semantics however
um I don't know of any real just like
you know Chomsky talks about facts about
language which is an old-fashioned
notion and but I really think that's
kind of an important notion too right
like is there some discovery about
language itself that llms can uniquely
provide so like if llm's made some
prediction about let's say you have a
sentence structure Type X being more
difficult to process than sentence type
Y and this is a unique prediction that
only they'd generate it and no human
linguist Chomsky homestein none of these
people had ever predicted that before
but it turns out to be true you do eye
tracking experiments you do all sorts of
different behavioral experience and oh
you know after all it turns out to be
true this this is a new insight about
language processing it's a new insight
about language you know Behavior I just
wonder I'm not saying I'm not saying
that this is not possible in principle
because it might happen in the near
future but that's I guess for me the
Crux of why a lot of linguists speaking
of speaking on behalf of the entire
Linguistics Community here and you know
I guess that would be one of the main
objections
yeah I mean I I don't know of of uh I I
guess I I think of the insights they've
provided as kind of general principles
right so
um uh I think about these things like
the the the power of memorizing chunks
of language right so like they're they
seem to be very good at constructions
for example and there's lots of
linguistic theories chomsky's in
particular right which are uh about
trying to find kind of minimal amounts
of of structure to memorize right trying
to derive as much as possible from from
um some small set some small collection
of of operations
um and I think that hasn't gone well for
those theories right um whereas this
goes really well right so
um uh if we think about something which
has the memorization abilities if we
think about theories of grammar for
example which uh build on
um you know humans like really
remarkable ability to to memorize
different constructions right or
different words we know tens of
thousands of words tens of thousands of
different constructions sorry tens of
thousands of different idioms maybe our
theory of grammar should be integrated
with that and they're in some sense a
kind of proof of principle that that
kind of approach can work well right
um can think about making other types of
predictions with them um some of which
people uh are are currently doing but
for example trying to use them to
measure uh processing difficulty measure
surprisal for example from from these
models
um there are surprisal measures right
are
much better than say context-free
grammars or other kinds of language
models and then it's interesting
question how those uh surprisles or
predictabilities relate to human
processing right and it may capture some
of it or might be non-linear or it might
you know only capture a little bit of it
or or whatever that's an interesting
kind of other scientific question but I
think in principle right they they can
make predictions about for example the
connections between sentences right so
in in the paper I gave this example of
you know converting a declaration into a
question in 10 different ways right and
presumably when it when you know GPT or
something is is doing that it's finding
10 different questions which are all uh
in some way related kind of nearby in
the models underlying semantic or
syntactic space
um and so those kinds of things are uh
of the type that I think
um uh you know some linguists might want
right which is here's some hidden
connection between sentences or their or
their structures but as far as I know
they haven't been evaluated empirically
yet so right yeah yeah I mean these
kinds of models are only a few years old
so I I think it's
um it's reasonable to be excited about
them even though this kind of work
hasn't been done yet no that's right no
totally totally I mean but I think I
think that's that's the right
perspective to take but I think this
gets to the issue of the
um you mentioned surprisal you mentioned
laneability
um you know LMS and some syntax but they
do so with obviously way way more data
than infants do
um such that observations of potential
structure in and of itself is not a
reputation of the poverty of the
stimulus well the weaker version I
should say of the poverty of
distinguished argument so the mere fact
that LMS can do what they do with our
grammatical prize is very striking I
agree and in fact you wouldn't have
predicted that maybe five or six or
seven years ago
um but it doesn't yeah invalidate the
claim that humans have surprise and we
bring those prayers with us and so in
order to see if computational
Linguistics can constrain hypotheses and
theoretical Linguistics which I think it
can do by the way this needs to be done
with you know careful experiments in
which different learning parameters are
controlled and gigantic language models
like gbt free are basically you know
useless here and this so this gets to
some of tile lens and complaints that we
need something like a baby LM project
which I know you're interested in and
where we have more you know ecologically
valid training sets you make the
prediction in your paper that some
structure will be learned from that I
suspect you you might be right there
um but you know even so even with the
baby LM challenge there's still the kind
of non-trivial issue of addressing more
traditional issues like when the kids
start to generalize based on the amount
of current input based on different
factors cross-linguistically and that
requires just traditional you know
psycholinguistics and language
acquisition so LMS you know do care
about things like frequency and
surprisal as you said but there's a
really nice paper by Sophie and
Andrea Martin the really beautiful paper
and that I think you may have seen that
shows very nicely that distributional
statistics can sometimes be a cue to
moments of structure building but it
does replace these Notions pertaining to
composition so I'll just read a quote
from Chomsky 57 which sounds a lot like
what um slots and more and say despite
undeniable interests and importance
um of semantic and statistical models of
language they appear to have no direct
relevance to the problem of determining
or characterizing the set of grammatical
differences I think that we are forced
to conclude that grammar is autonomous
and independent of meaning and that
probabilistic models give no particular
insight into some of the basic problems
of syntactic structure so that second uh
hedge of the of the of the second
sentence turned out to be incorrect but
it's so it's true that you know what's
obviously said are available stat models
in 57 is no longer accurate when applied
to models today and that can make
abstract generalizations about novel
strings and distributional categories as
you mentioned right but the performance
of a single model does not provide
direct evidence for or against the
landability of a particular structure by
giving the vast distance between any
computational model available today and
the human brain model success does not
mean that the structure is necessarily
land and model failure also doesn't mean
that the structure is not learnable
right
yeah yeah so I I mean I think it's maybe
worth unpacking kind of a couple
different versions of learnability
arguments that people have made because
there have been uh very very strong kind
of impossibility claims
um coming out of kind of chomsky's
tradition right that we're we're never
claims about the amount of data that was
required right there were claims about
The Logical problem of language learning
and that it was just impossible
um right it was impossible without
having uh uh uh kind of substantial
constraints on the the class of
languages or the class of grammars that
that you would you would acquire
um and people for a long time have been
arguing against that that version of
things
um
um you know there's there's old work by
by gold and then there's whole kind of
grammatical theories of acquisition
built on that tradition uh that worry a
lot about the the kind of uh order in
which you Traverse through different
hypotheses and consider different
options and things
um
um and my favorite reference in in this
is is this paper by
um Nick jader and Paul vetani um called
something like ideal learning of of
natural language
um that basically shows that a
unconstrained learner could uh with
enough data acquire the uh the the kind
of generating rules or the the
generating grammar
um just from observing strings right but
that that that paper was was really in
in response to this huge body of work
that that was arguing that that learning
from positive examples so from just
observing strings was was like logically
impossible right so
um uh of course you know people in in
chomsky's Tradition really liked that
form of argument because it was one that
said uh you had to have something
innately uh specified in order for
language acquisition to work it was like
kind of a mathematical argument right
that you had to have uh some some kind
of innate grammar or innate ordering of
hypotheses or something and all of that
just turned out to be totally wrong so
um if you uh you know move to slightly
more kind of realistic learning settings
which Tater and vatani do
um uh then it turns out you like an
idealized learner can acquire stuff and
there's no statements about
um the amount of data that's required
even there right that's the the kind of
pure logical uh ability to learn
um and that ability is is what I think
the uh big versions of large language
models also speak to right so Chader
invitani and other other work kind of in
that that Spirit
um is you know mathematical and kind of
arguing in principle but but never
created something which was really a uh
a grammar right or or a a real kind of
implemented language model
um so even you know a model which is
trained on 100 million or 100 billion or
however many many tokens right
um uh even that kind of model I think is
relevant to that version of of the
debate right and and and showing that uh
language learning is is not impossible
um from a very unconstrained space okay
and then then there's a second version
right which is uh can we learn language
with the specific data that kids get
right and that's both amount of data and
and form of the data
um and so for people who don't know the
the baby LM challenge
um uh is
um uh this uh
um sorry thing to call it a a
competition or a
um a uh uh I guess it is a a challenge
um trying to get people to to train
language models on human-sized amounts
of data um so that's something more like
um I think there's two different
versions 10 or 100 million different
um to 10 or 100 million different words
in the the training set
um which is like you know 100th or
1000th or something as as big as
um these big AI companies are using for
their language models um and
um I think actually it's it's like
that's exactly the the right kind of
thing and exactly what the field needs
right because you might find that on
um a child-sized amount of data
um you can essentially learn syntax
right which I I think would would be the
strongest argument against these Poverty
of stimulus claims you could
alternatively find that
um maybe you can't learn very much
um maybe you you you know come up with a
a much crummier kind of language model
or it's lacking some syntactic or
semantic abilities
um
um I actually think that the the
failures there are a little bit hard to
interpret because
um kids uh data when they're actually
learning language they get a lot more
data than just uh just strings of
sentences right they're interacting in
in an environment
um so there's stuff in the world in
front of them um their utterances are
also interactive right so you can say
something and and see whether your
parent brings you the thing that you ask
for for example right that's long been
been argued by people
um um as a a you know important cue in
in language acquisition
um so
um uh in the baby LM challenge there
there is an ability to train these
models uh with kind of multimodal inputs
I think you can give them as much video
data as as you want to give
um uh but probably it's hard to to kind
of replicate exactly the type of setup
and and feedback that kids actually get
so
um uh I don't know you know I'm I'm
excited to to see uh where that goes and
and how things pan out there
um
um uh you know I I think that there's an
interesting related question for large
language models
um which is like what it which is
understanding exactly what all of the
data is doing so
um it could be that that you need so
much data for these models because
they're effectively inventing some form
of semantics internally right so
um they're both discovering the rule of
syntax and there they appear to be
learning uh quite a bit about word
meanings
um and
um it's not it's totally unclear I think
how much of the the data in these modern
models uh is needed for syntax versus
semantics
um my own guess I think would would be
that the syntactic side is uh probably
requires much less data than the than
the semantic side
um actually a student a former student
of mine Frank Malika and I wrote a paper
a few years ago trying to estimate the
amount of information a learner would
necessarily have to acquire
um for uh learning the different aspects
of language so you have to learn all the
words and you learn their forums you
learn their meanings you probably know
their frequencies you have to learn
syntax and basically what we found
um in that analysis that was you know
basically just a kind of back of the
envelope calculation for each of these
domains is that syntax is actually very
few bits of information it doesn't take
that much information to to learn syntax
whereas like most of the information you
you acquire is actually for semantics so
specifying you know 30 to 50 000
different word meanings you know if even
if each meaning is
um uh just a few bits right like that
that requires a lot of information and
probably each meeting is more than a few
bits right so
um uh it could be like that that would
make me guess that what's happening with
with large language models is most of
their training data is about word
semantics and you can think about other
ways that kids get word semantics right
that's that's not just kind of
co-occurrence patterns in in text
um but I I agree all of that is is up in
the air and and really exciting to see
what will happen so yeah I know that
some of the earlier results from it from
Lindsay's lab suggests that at least
restricted to ecologically valid you
know training sites uh models seem to
generalize you know linear rules for
English yes no question formation ROM
other than the hierarchical rule the
correct hierarchy rule so I think
there's a real sense in which you know
this the the the space of the correct
syntactic price and inductive biases
really is is yet to be really settled on
but it seems at least to me pretty
obvious that there has to be some so
there's also some evidence
um that children in English going back
to this frequency issue that children in
English sometimes spell out an
intermediate copy of movement in the
specified position of the lower
complementizer position of a long
distance wh question so there's a thesis
by Thornton and some other papers about
this so they say um which person do you
think who did that rather than which
person do you think did that so this is
an interesting you know Miss setting
because some languages do actually spell
out these intermediate copies but
English doesn't so the kid makes the
error in setting their grammar but the
frequency of the input is actually zero
and so our mutual friend Gary Marcus
also has an argument against frequency
determining a kid's output in the case
of German noun plurals a more regular
form of the certain kind is preferred
not the frequent one and there's lots of
examples like so it's sometimes claimed
that subject experience passives where
the subject is passively experiencing
something or very delayed in kids in
comprehension studies until around eight
because they're not very frequent in the
input
But Ken Wexler and colleagues have gone
through um subject experience Double H
questions like who likes Mary and they
discovered that these are as infrequent
in the input as subject and experience
of passives but kids have no problem in
comprehension studies of these questions
but they do have problems comprehending
subject experience of verbal passives so
frequency once again seems to be
irrelevant or at least it's not
explanatory right I guess it's not
explanatory with respect to Theory
building so how can LMS help with these
you know diverging cases when there's
clearly something else going on besides
frequency so alums you know they seem to
generalize just again going back to this
issue of the the cases that you have in
your paper and you show that they
generalize the structure of colorless
screen ideas which is often very cool
um but the positive stimulus has never
really been about not being able to
learn language statistically I know you
made that claim right but chomsky's
point in the 50s about statistical
models of the day is not true of
commercial LMS in 2023 and that's
correct but we can't use that single
point to undermine you know the entire
geometry Enterprise chomsky's basic
point was that you could have a
grammatical structure wherein every
diagram has zero frequency and it also
fails to provide clearly interpretable
instructions to the conceptual
interfaces so interfaces of other
systems of the mind so as you're showing
your paper GPT mimics examples like pull
the screen ideas and but you know again
this sentence yields over 150 000
results on Google and it's discussed
extensively in the literature it's able
to mimic the fact that it can mimic this
doesn't really tell us much at least we
can't really say anything with much
confidence so you know abiba behind at
University College Dublin has this quote
recently uh do not mistake your own
gullibility for an lm's intelligence and
in fact even young the wrote last
year that critics are right to accuse
LMS of being engaged in a kind of
mimicry
um and the example sentences from gbt
that you give in the paper actually
don't do a good job because as you say
it's likely that you know meaningless
languages rare in the training data but
they can either do it or they can't but
there's no middle ground in terms of
giving us 10 examples like this so you
have colorless green ideas which are
very different semantic objects from
things like brown shimmering rabbits
white glittery Bears uh black shiny
kangaroos green glittering monkeys
yellow dazzling Lions red shimming
elements right these are all like
semantic semantically weird and a bit
strange but they're still like legal
structures they're kind of meaningful
synthetic semantic objects
um right
I I just said yeah yeah
I I I I mean so I I maybe I can I can
respond to the first point first right
so
um uh you started off talking about
these other uh kinds of acquisition
patterns which maybe don't map directly
onto to frequency
um and I I think it's actually a mistake
to think that uh kind of modern learning
models should be just based on frequency
because
um they're clearly learning like pretty
complicated families of rules or
constructions or something and
um I think it's very likely that when
they're they're learning that they're
um in some sense searching for a simple
or parsimonious
um uh explanation of the data that
they've seen right and how that caches
out in a in a neural network is is maybe
complicated and you know it depends on
um you know parameters and the specifics
of the learning algorithm and and and
those kind of things
um but I think it's it's uh I I guess
I'd suspect maybe that that it's likely
to be the case that
um uh like they're they're they're
learning over a complicated set of
things right a complicated kind of
family of of rules and constructions
um and that means I I think that
um their generalizations may be like the
examples of people that that you gave
um might be kind of discontinuous in the
input right so sometimes you you you
could imagine seeing some strings which
leads you to a grammar and the simplest
grammar of the data that that you've
seen so far is one which predicts an
unseen string right and
um if that happens then you'll be uh
taking the data learning a
representation which generalizes in some
novel unseen way so far
um purely because that generalization is
is sort of the simplest account of the
data that you've seen scene to date
right I think that's sort of what
linguists tried to do right try to uh
look at the data and come up with the
theory of it and then sometimes that
theory predicts some new phenomenon
right or some some new type of sentence
and so if they're learning over a
sufficiently rich space of theories
um then it wouldn't be you know
unreasonable or unexpected for for them
to also show those kinds of patterns now
whether they they do or not I think is
is still an open empirical question
right
um because we have to train them on
small amounts of data and test their
generalizations and and these kind of
things
um but I don't think like just the fact
that
um you know humans do things which are
not purely based on frequency is any
evidence at all either way right because
once you're learning over rich and
interesting classes of theories then
that that is the expected behavior
um actually I I had um a paper about a a
year ago that I think you're you're
familiar with
um uh Yang and and pianta dosi where
where we were
um uh looking at
um uh kind of what happens when you give
a program learning model strings from uh
different formal languages so think of
like
um giving a a general model just you
know 10 or 20 maybe simple strings that
obey some pattern and then asking it to
find a program which uh can explain that
data which often means you know finding
um uh finding some way of kind of
programmatically writing down the the
pattern in in the strings
um and in that figure we we have a paper
which is really relevant to to this
point where
um the uh generalizations that that kind
of model makes
um uh are I think kind of qualitatively
like the ones you're describing for
people right where
um uh you can give them a small amount
of data and it will predict unseen
strings with very high probability
um even though there's zero frequency in
the training input right and the reason
it does that is that often the most
concise computational description of the
data that you've seen is one that
predicts some particular uh new unseen
output so that that model is is
essentially an implementation of the the
kind of Chader and Vitani program
learning
um idea that that I brought up earlier
um but it it's one that that I think you
know if you think about in the context
of these arguments of kids saying
unusual or unexpected things like that
is predicted by all of these kinds of
accounts right because as long as as
long as these things are effectively
comparing an interesting space of
grammars
um then they'll they'll show that that
kind of behavior I think
uh yeah so okay so I guess you know
the argument would be that at least from
the gender perspective syntax is
functioning separately but it's still
mapped to semantics it informs
pragmatics right so in the Middle East
program syntax is obviously meaningless
it's very small it's just it's just a
linearization and labeling they're the
two only operations you have a
linearization algorithm to centromotor
systems and some kind of categorization
algorithm at the at the um Center at the
conceptual systems
um so chomsky's architecture is kind of
reliant on the process of mapping syntax
to semantics right it's foam meaning
regulation it's not just structure and
it's not just meaning so LMS don't
really have this mapping process right
like where's the mapping to semantics
and if there is a mapping what do the
what does the mapping process look like
what are the properties of its semantics
uh you know what do these what the
properties of the semantics place on
their own sets of constraints on the
marketing process like they do for
natural language are they kind of you
know uh do do these kind of constraints
inform each other is they kind of a back
and forth process right like elements
don't really seem to describe this form
meaning pairing correct like which
meanings which strings for example right
well sorry are you saying that
um that that they don't have semantics
at all or are you saying that there's
just not a clear uh delineation between
how the structures get mapped onto the
semantics yeah the latter right so they
clearly have some potentially some kind
of semantics I know you've argued for a
conceptual role Theory being relevant
here right the rest of it maybe little
bit more mysterious but the actual soy
Linguistics at the very there's a theory
of the mapping process itself it's
explicit and you can see it in action
and you can test different theories of
it in Psych linguistic models and what
have you the the actual regulation the
kind of you know constrained ambiguity
ambiguity in the sense of you know one
word multiple meanings or one structure
multiple interpretations Etc right
yeah I mean if you think they have
semantics then then I think they have to
have a mapping from the syntax to the
semantics
um I agree it's it's not as like nobody
really understands how they're working
on any deep level right so I so I agree
it's it's not as clear as
um say in in generative syntax and
semantics right where
um you know you kind of write down the
the rules of of composition and and can
derive a compositional meaning from a
sentence from the component parts or
something right like that's
um you know that's not how they're
working right but
um I I just I I wouldn't take for
granted that it has to be like that like
um uh it could be that how they're
working is actually how we work right
that uh everything is represented in
some high dimensional Vector space and
there's some complicated uh way in which
that Vector semantics gets updated with
each additional word or whatever
um in in a linguistic stream
um but like I I think think it's clear
that they have some kind of
representation of the semantics of a
sentence right like they can answer
questions for example at least
approximately I mean it's not not
perfect but
um it's it's not like a engram model or
something right which really doesn't
have doesn't have semantics so
um I I think that they're
um they're they're definitely
representing semantics and
um uh you know updating that as they as
they process language it just happens
not to look like these other formal
theories
um and I I guess I I don't see why
that's a problem right like those other
formal theories could just be you know
poor approximations or or just totally
wrong right yeah
yeah yeah no totally totally I mean
there's also ways in which some of the
formal theories in semantics are already
potentially compatible with what some of
these things are doing right so another
way to think about this is you know LMS
are well LMS are compression algorithms
but natural language understanding is
kind of all more about decompression
it's disambiguating meaning X Out of
meanings XYZ it's all about making
inferences about you know meta relations
between Concepts that are not in the
training data so some examples that
Melanie Mitchell gives out things like
on top of you know she's on top of again
uh it's on top of the box all these kind
of vary with context so there's a lot of
other things that are going on right
um and I think you discuss some of those
examples in your paper so you know
um but the faculty of language is still
not at least again under this theory of
language and it's not about string
generation it's about this form meaning
pairing machine so sometimes this in the
genitive tradition even think all there
is to semantics is just and right so
Paul petrovsky's conjunctive is there
some is that human semantics is just and
that's it
um which again is is very simple elegant
it's it's it's it's interpretable it's
compatible with a lot of the things that
you know or maybe going on in in your
neck of the words right but regardless
it's still you know natural language is
still more compositional
them things like uh you know formal
languages just to make a clear
distinction that's been made they have a
much richer composition of structure
there's more stuff going on uh maybe so
it's been pointed out before that you
know things like attention-based machine
mechanisms and Transformers
um allow for combinations of discrete
token bindings which is more approximate
to a merge like operator than simple
recurrent matrix multiplication
um but you know the issue of binary
branching binary branching government
just to choose another example here to
talk about the full meaning regulation
one principle binary branching image is
an interesting question but geometry
grammar has always been open to
different Origins and locations of this
apparent constraint in synthetic
computation right like where does it
come from maybe it's a condition on
merge maybe it's imposed by a smooth
system maybe it's a kind of Prior you
know who knows and in fact it's some
more recent working generative grammar
has tried to ground and do away with all
theoretic assumptions of of marriage
right maybe set theory isn't the best
way to model
um the generative grammar maybe Maria
logical accounts are more appropriate
there's lots of other recent ideas there
which which are all compatible with the
with chomsky's approach right in fact
yeah one of the things that Trump get
likes the most is when he's when he's
proven wrong right A lot of these
theories are drawing against the core
mainstream minimalist architecture but
that yeah I think so it's a very diverse
like vibrant field the people who are
Bornstein you know petrovsky uh uh
hajipura they disagree in fundamental
ways with a lot of what the mainstream
of chemical grammar would say but
there's still more scope for
disagreement but it's still compatible
with setting core assumptions right so a
lot of David I just wear for example
kind of deviates in this core respect
but it's still trying to ground these
intuitions in in different formal
systems
um so you know
it's kind of
I want to get your thoughts again on um
I mentioned Mitchell right so Michelin
Bowers uh 2020 they have this paper
trial list recurrent networks laying
curiously that I think you might be
aware of right so it's a really good
example just to kind of get to the heart
of the issue so recurrent neural
networks have been shown to accurately
model you know non-verb number agreement
but Mitchell and Barrow showed that
these networks will also land a number
agreement with unnatural sentence
structures so structures that are not
found in natural language and which
humans have a hard time processing right
so the mode of learning for rnns is at
least for rnn's positively distinct from
from infant you know infant Homo sapiens
right so the story is Mitchell and
Bowers show that while the lstl model
has a good representation of singular
versus plural for individual sentences
there's no generalization going on right
they can represent at the individual
level so the model doesn't have a
representation of number as an
abstraction what number is only concrete
instances of singular basis plural
um so successfully predicting language
Behavior via LM or successfully
predicting neural responses in a similar
way is obviously great and maybe we can
get into that issue later but there's
only one side of the coin here right the
other side of the coin is explaining why
this type of behavior and not some other
Behavior why this structure I'm not
similar and that's maybe chomsky's most
and like you know his most important
Point really why this are not some other
system so linguistic Theory kind of
gives you that or the start of the coin
right whereas LM is really done so the
Mitchell embarrassed paper does
something like that he does it
well yeah so like take um Yael Le crets
and stanislash the Haynes were from 2019
right they looked at number agreement in
an lstm and found two specialized units
that encoded number agreement but the
overall contribution to Performance was
low and then in 2021 uh yeah corrects
had this paper where they show that
um in their neural language model it did
not achieve genuine recursive processing
of nested long range agreement gender
marking in Italian I think
um even if some hierarchical processing
what you know was achieved as you've
argued before right some hierarchy was
left it was there but the question is is
it the right mapping is it the right
kind of hierarchy they found that
lstn-based models could land subject web
agreement over short spans one degree of
embedding but they failed at some longer
dependencies and in the most recent
paper uh La crepe satell with the hand
and showed that they evaluated modern
Transformer LMS including gpt2 XL on the
same task and the Transformers perform
more similarly to humans than LSM did
and performed above transfer overall but
they still perform below chance in one
key condition which is the as I
mentioned the multiple embedding one the
difficult scriptures and so the reason
why I mentioned these studies is because
you know it's not just to explore the
limits of OMS which is an interesting
question
um but consider work by people like Neil
Smith at UCL right and he did work in
the 90s with a polyglot Savant and
neurotypical controls comparing them so
he investigated second language learning
of an artificial language containing
both natural and unnatural graphical
structures like the Michelin virus paper
right the whole framework is natural
versus unnatural and they found that
while both the savant
and the controls could Master the
linguistically natural aspects only the
controls could eventually handle the
structure dependent unnatural phenomena
and neither of them could Master the
structure independent aspects so some
weird rules where it's like you know you
mark the emphasis on the third word of
the sentence things like that so they
argue that Christopher's abilities are
entirely due to his intact linguistic
faculties but the controls could employ
more domain General kind of cognitive
resources like you know attention
control Etc which is why they could deal
with difficult processes
but I just mentioned you know a minute
ago that the lstm in the Mitchell
embarrassed paper approaches natural and
unnatural structures in pretty much the
same way so it's not you know it's not a
psychologically plausible model I would
argue and for whatever humans are doing
and similar observations can apply to
the limits of Transformer models in La
creta's work and all of these themes are
like right up that they're staying with
us all the way to the present so another
one of talins recent papers that he
posted a few weeks ago looking at child
directed speech showed that um lstms and
Transformers limited to ecologically
plausible amounts of data generalized as
I mentioned the linear rules for English
right rather than the abstract rules and
in fact more recent work from linton's
Lab last week looking at uh well last
year I should say shows that looking at
Garden paths surprisal does not explain
uh syntactic disambiguation difficulty
right
um surprises will underpredicts the size
of the Garden Path effect across all
constructions and this gets to this
issue that you mentioned before you know
maybe surprised all this related uh to
some aspects of syntax but maybe not
other ones it's kind of a it's a very
non-tribute issue that is very much it's
open to to discussion it's not it hasn't
been settled yet but so Linton showed
that Garden Path effects are just way
more difficult than you would expect
from me unpredictability so another way
of phrasing this argument
um is the is the quote a recent argument
with chomsky's to get at this natural
basis unnatural issue he says suppose we
have an expanded periodic table that
includes all the elements that do exist
or the elements that can possibly exist
and all the elements that cannot
possibly exist and let's say you have
some model uh some artificial model that
fails to distinguish between these three
categories whatever this model is doing
it's not helping us understand chemistry
right it's doing something else it's
it's it's doing something for sure but
whether or not it's having to understand
chemistry is something separate and I
know that you've said in response to
some of these studies I think you've
said that you know and in order to show
that something is likely to be
impossible somewhere in your paper I
think you say
um in order to show that something is
impossible with normal balance of
Politics on false positives you need to
show you need to look at something like
500 independently sampled languages so
you cite this in the paper right
um which you probably can't do that's
just not it's not a feasible thing to do
and so you know I'm not I'm not too sure
that this really refutes the principal
argument that I'm making here right
because people like Michelin Bowers are
making an argument about impossibility
in principle not
um in some kind of extensional sense you
know just like searching across the
world languages to see to prove across
every single language that it is
impossible right that's kind of it's a
different argument whether it's
impossible in some random language in
the Amazon compared to actually
impossible based on the principles of
what the language system is actually
doing like what it can do so I would
just say that yeah I think that that
that point is is that you don't actually
know what is typologically not possible
right so some people like to say things
like you know there's no language that
does X therefore we have to build that
restriction into our our statistical
models right but if it's not
statistically Justified that there is no
language that does X right if you've
only looked at 20 or 20 European
languages or something right I I mean
it's it's not
um uh like that shouldn't motivate doing
anything to the models right
um uh if it's if it's not a
statistically Justified Universal I
think
um
well you know I I I think you know
you're totally right but that just
applies more generally to the social
sciences and psychological Sciences
right like typologically yeah it's very
difficult to establish these things
right so I guess you I guess you're just
kind of stale man you're a bit you're
saying that the strong claim is very
difficult to prove right
like there is no language that has X the
the strong claim that something is not
allowed in in natural language is I
think very very difficult to prove
um
um and you know I I think that there
have been uh lots of you know strong
attempts there's been lots of strong
claims from
um uh often from from generative syntax
right about what all languages do
um and I think that you know people have
been very good at at finding kind of
counter examples to to a lot of those
things I cite this this paper by Evans
and and Levinson
um which actually you know I I had heard
for years about how no language does X
and and that's what we're using to
construct our theories and that Evans
and Levin's paper Evans and Levinson
paper really uh kind of changed my mind
about this right that like language is
actually much more uh diverse than than
I think most
um most syntacticians will you know try
to construct theories for something so
um um you know I I I think we going back
to kind of the the beginning of what you
said I think we we'd agree that that uh
you need language architectures which
learn the things that kids learn and
learned it from data that they learn and
those architectures might might be
unlikely to be things like lstms or you
know simple recurrent networks or or
whatever right like
um I think all of that work is is very
useful in in kind of honing in on the
right architecture
um
uh so I'm just trying to to remember all
of all of the the points you were making
oh yeah so
um but I I think this that there there's
a a kind of Flip Side to to this which
is that
um I think that the space of things
people can learn is actually uh kind of
underestimated right like there's this
bias to to to say you know people can't
learn x y and z
um but people uh at least outside of
language have this this really
remarkable ability to learn different
kinds of patterns right like the
patterns you find in in music or
mathematics for example
um uh we can learn sophisticated types
of of algorithms right we can learn to
you know fly a space shuttle or to you
know tie knots in for rock climbing or
whatever right like there there's all
kinds of uh kind of procedural and
algorithmic knowledge which is
structural that that people are able to
acquire and I think that that that uh
notion uh very rightly kind of motivates
looking for learning systems which can
work over pretty unrestricted spaces
right so
um uh you know you you you might say
that okay well language is different
because language is a restricted space
um uh and it might be true that that
language is restricted but it also might
be true that the things we see in
language come from other sources right
it could be that uh language is
especially pragmatic for example
compared to uh music or mathematics
right and those kinds of pragmatic
constraints
um are the things that constrain the
form of language right or language is
communicative it's probably more
communicative than than music for
example and that might constrain the the
form of things so I mean as as you know
this is very old debate in in
linguistics about kind of where the uh
where the properties of of natural
language come from
um and uh I guess what I'm trying to say
is that there's one kind of perspective
where uh you look at all of the things
humans can do even outside of language
all of the rich structures and
algorithms and processes were able to
learn about about and internalize and
you say okay maybe language is like that
and then yes language also has some of
these other funny little properties
um but you know maybe those come from
some other other pieces of of where
language comes from right it's uh it's
you know we have pretty sophisticated
pragmatic reasoning
um uh we're using it to achieve certain
communicative ends you can find all
kinds of kind of communicative features
uh within the the language system itself
and so so maybe some of these other
properties are are properties that have
some other origin
um and that that view I think could be
wrong but it's it's one that
um I think needs to be looked at to see
if it's wrong right like I I think it's
been
um uh kind of dismissed um by uh large
chunks of of linguists right just you
know I've heard people say stuff like oh
well communication doesn't really
explain anything about language right
and what they mean often is it doesn't
explain like the particular Island
constraints or something that they're
that they're working on right but
there's all kinds of other things in
language that communicative pressures
probably do explain
um so
um I I guess my my pitch is always for
for kind of breadth in term breadth in
consideration of uh the forces that that
can shape language and not needing to
put it all into some form of of innate
constraints or something like that no
totally and I think I think a lot of
that stuff is is compatible with with
them illness program
because the middle of this program wants
syntax to be minimal it doesn't want it
to be complicated it doesn't want it to
be you know any more complicated it has
to be so there were some you mentioned
the the Curious properties right so
there are some of the properties that
need to be accounted for in any model of
language that uh I'll give you an
example right the setting of a person
features
and these person features exhibit very
non-trivial different generalizations
that do not seem to be accounted for Via
domain General learning mechanism so I'm
sitting here the work of Daniel Harper
at Queen Mary so for example the
morphological composition of person it's
interaction with number it's connection
to space uh properties of its semantics
and it's linearization they all appear
to be strong candidates for our
knowledge of language right what we mean
by knowledge of language but on the
other hand we have things like case and
agreement and head movement and these
are all structural phenomena however
they seem to resist a purely
meaning-based explanation uh in
theoretical Linguistics right it would
be great if syntax were nothing but a
computational engine that build
structured meaning and that's the
minimalist program the goal but that's
not what we actually find that's not in
any actual minimalist like concrete
model any concrete mineralist Theory the
goal is just like the program is
language is perfect okay that's the
program is that what we find no
obviously not okay no no linguist
actually believes that and so it would
be great if syntax was like that but I
think you know the program is to look
for Perfection but not always find it so
case an agreement and head movement are
morphological more for phonological
phenomenal the properties of the
performance systems what's called
performance systems and so the
minimalist program itself is really
compatible with a lot of what you're
saying about you know language language
there are aspects of language that can
be um perfected and optimized for
communicative efficiency absolutely
totally no doubt about it but where is
that locus of efficiency is it in the
syntax itself or is it some kind of
extra linguistic system is it in
pragmatics you know is it in sensory
motor is it in the speech
um probably the speech and phonology
probably you know I mean who knows but I
think a lot of these things demand much
more you know serious consideration into
old-fashioned Notions like structure
dependence compositional theme what have
you things like that which you can maybe
find somewhere in the literature but
um even just basic topics like you know
um quantifier raising extended
projections
um adverbial like adverbial hierarchies
all of these things in the minimalist
program can be extra linguistic right
they can actually be outside of syntax
and query very queer properties of the
semantic uh conceptual systems which are
in themselves kind of domain General
weird leftovers from ancient primary
cognition right the features of the way
we pass events the way we pass you know
agents and patients things like that
that's definitely not that's not human
specific
um but you know the way that syntax
provides instructions to these systems
you know properly seems to be so you
know generative linguists have different
theories of also language production too
I'll just talk about language production
based on whether we store lemmas or
whether we build words in the exact same
way we will phrase and sentences so I
know that you you make the distinction
between construction grammar and kind of
generative grammar and you know the the
weight they place on memorizing
constrictions whereas is just building
things from from the bottom up from the
ground up right and so you know in some
generative inspired models mechanisms
which generate syntactic structure make
no distinctions between processes that
apply above or below the word level
there's no pointer which meaning syntax
and form are all stored together a
single Atomic representations each stage
in lexical access is a transition
between different kinds of data
structures right there's meaning there's
form and there's syntax these three
features kind of co-mingle together and
they don't always overlap different
languages realize them in different ways
and so you know a weird the basic
definition of a word is just this weird
multi-system definition and where lots
of things lots of different cognitive
systems enrich the basis of every
electrical item right you have
um there's nothing like this really this
enrichment process
um anywhere else in in linguistic Theory
right or at least in what llms are doing
like
so I guess what what I guess I'll ask
you what is your definition of a word
right and what can llms really provide
insights into word Hood right because if
you kind of if you don't have a
destination of what a word is then
you're really in trouble right like we
have to at least use LMS or artificial
systems to inform what we mean by a word
or maybe we don't need that anymore I'm
not sure what do you think I I'm not I'm
not sure what you mean I mean
um
um I I don't have a what is a word why
does that matter I mean that that that's
just a convention about how we use the
term word right what like
I mean you could use you know lemmas or
word firms or or whatever like that that
just feels like a conventional Choice
I'm I'm not sure what's it what's at
stake there
so how would you I guess I I would say I
agree word is a conventionalization you
know icons aren't intuitive concept of
where it is often biased by orthography
the way we put spaces things right so so
that I I agree with that criticism you
know word in the intuitive sense is not
really a scientific construct however I
guess let me rephrase my question how
would you um you know decompose the
intuitive concept of word into something
that is more kind of you know
scientifically amenable or
psychologically plausible which is
exactly what geometric primary tries to
do by decomposing words into you know
distinctive features uh morphological
categories conceptual Roots being merged
with categorical features you know you
get a concept you know and you've made
it with a noun or a category to get a
noun or Affair these different models
make different predictions right yeah I
mean I I think that general idea is
likely to be right for large language
models like I think they kind of must
have things that are kind of like part
of speech categories for example
um and I think that they they kind of
must be able to uh update those their
categories based on the language that
they've seen so far right so like like
you know GPT puts nouns and verbs in the
right places and to to do that you kind
of need some representation of the nouns
versus the verbs and you need some
ability to uh uh locate yourself in a
string of other words and figure out if
there's likely to be a noun or or a verb
next
um so I I think that that on on that
level those kinds of properties of words
uh are very likely to to be right and
there there are also things which are uh
um very likely to be found kind of in
the internal representations of of these
models I don't see how it could be any
other way uh other than that
um but like as as far as I know that
that's not where the uh uh that's not
where the main debates or or
disagreement I think is right like
um uh yeah I think all theories of
language have to have to say that
there's different kinds of words that
can show up in different places or
something like that
um yeah
okay so how about the issue you know you
mentioned communication right
um so you know and you're totally right
when Trump see says things like language
is a thought system or you know language
didn't evolve he's kind of being a
little bit cheeky he doesn't really mean
that he kind of means in a very specific
sense right
um but you know when we say language is
a thought system what we mean is
um we're trying to get it an
architectural claim so if you look at
the architecture of the minimalist
program
the syntactic derivation and the
conceptual systems are literally
different systems right the conceptual
systems take stuff from syntax and then
to their own business with it and the CI
systems have their own peculiar rules
and and principles which is why I
thought in language are both similar
symbolic compositional systems but in
different ways only a subset of thought
is properly called the the CI interface
System since the CI systems are by
definition you know whatever conceptual
systems human have that can't access and
read out instructions from syntax and we
don't know what they are fully they seem
to have something to do with events in
grammatical reference and definiteness
they seem to be the main categories that
language you know cares about
conceptually
but we don't really know that's kind of
just a hypothesis right
um but what we do know is that they
don't seem to make use of color all that
much or um so no language
morphologically marks you know shades of
color
um or other conceptual features like um
um worry or concern like no language
morphologically marks a degree of worry
or concern about an issue but we do make
use of like um
epistemological Notions like
evidentiality and things like that so
you know one well I guess what I'm
saying is the minimalist program does a
good job of trying to figure out which
aspects of thought language is
intimately tied to and which aspects of
thought it's not tied to so the Midwest
program allows us to kind of carve that
up quite neatly and and this is a much
more nuanced framework than you know
when chomski says languages thought
again he doesn't maybe he means it maybe
he doesn't but that's not what the
actual architecture of his theory says
it's a rhetorical device that is very
you know useful and interesting to
attract undergraduate audiences whatever
if you look at actual theories that are
coming out of The Mentalist program no
one really believes language equals
thought right the language system seems
to it tries its best to access and
reformat and manipulate various
conceptual systems but it has its limits
right we know what systems spell Keys
core knowledge systems are hooked up to
with respect to the syntax engine and
which ones are not
um so you know this kind of gets back to
the idea that lexisation of a concept
seems to maybe alter it in some way it
kind of imbues it with elements that are
not there in the concept itself so if
you lecture is a concept you suddenly
transform it a little bit you give it a
little extra you sprinkle something else
on top of it and that seems to vary
across different nanotypes and but these
are all like very clear architectural
claims within geometric grammar that
make very clear empirical predictions so
in other words I guess what I'm saying
is
all these neuropsychology studies that
are up incited you know in a lot of work
um in this vein what does it really show
I think it shows that you know when
language is damaged in the brain it
loses this particular sway or mode of
influencing those systems but there's no
real prediction from within the Gen gram
Enterprise but those non-linguistic
systems should be impaired or should
suddenly you know shut down if the core
language system
um is compromised right in fact if
anything that just emphasizes the
principal divorce between the syntactic
system and non-linguistic systems right
so I think the a lot of predictions here
from the language and communication uh
you know literature are kind of missing
the point of the architectural claims
um I I can just give or Daniel do you
want to go uh give a little bit of a
background there so so there's these
papers
um uh from uh uh EV federenko and and
rosemary Varley that that are
um examining
um uh uh in part of them aphasic patient
so so people who have impaired uh
linguistic abilities
um
um basically showing that with impaired
linguistic abilities you you
um Can can still have
um uh preserved kind of reasoning
abilities so people like Chess Masters
chess Grand Masters for example who are
obviously very good at at reasoning
um uh um might not have uh kind of
intact linguistic abilities
um and then complementing that that kind
of patient work there's also uh work
from ebb's Lab showing that
um uh the uh parts of the brain that
that care about uh language
um
um are separable from the parts of the
brain that care about other other
domains even ones with same kind of
language-like so things like like music
and and Mathematics
um uh tend not to happen in the in the
language areas
um so EV and others have have argued
that
um this is uh basically evidence against
the Chomsky and claim that uh that
language is the medium for thinking
right because there's thinking that can
happen in the absence of language and
brain areas that care about language
seem not to be the brain areas that they
care about care about thinking
um I I guess Elliot you're you're saying
that people don't don't really believe
that
um uh they don't believe that that
distinction I mean
um that uh
no it's it and also there's a lot of
like self-contradiction even Within
These arguments right so so in your
paper you sometimes say that Chomsky
thinks that language is a thought system
but then a few pages later you'll say
Chomsky also believes that syntax is
some totally separate system from
anything else right you autonomy of
syntax Etc so which is Chomsky thing
that's not my contradiction I mean he
said both of those things
um right exactly so so therefore you may
want to ask yourself does he really
believe these things or what is the
physical arises from from the from the
architecture right so just saying just
saying language is a thought system what
does that mean that doesn't mean
anything it's just a very vague
statement the question is how exactly is
language contributing to Thor and how is
it not contributing
uh yeah I mean I think his claim is is
mainly evolutionary or something right
that uh this is the the origins of of
the system which I think is is sort of
equally hard to square with
um uh the kind of patient and and
neuroimaging data
um
um but you know if if he doesn't think
that then he shouldn't say it or people
will respond to what he said I think
well no no because the argument is that
language is a kind of thought system it
regulates some aspects of though and it
and it yields some aspects of thought
that are clearly unique to humans but
it's not intrinsically or causally tied
to it right the the architecture of the
system is very different from the kind
of generalizations you can rhetorically
events from the architecture so for
instance when you site work from aphasic
patients showing no deficits in complex
reasoning as you just mentioned playing
chess and so on we would actually expect
this under a kind of you know
non-lexicalist framework of geometry
syntax where meaning as I said meaning
syntax and form form just meaning
anything that you can externalize
language and all these things are
separate features and separate systems
right the autonomy of syntax doesn't
mean
you know what a lot of people think it
means it just means either a certain
there are certain syntactic operations
that are not semantic there are certain
things you can do with syntax that you
can only do syntax and you can't do
semantics so this gets back to the
difference between you know uh
petrovsky's theory that semantics is
just and right versus the uh allows
synthetician's belief that there are
certain peculiar weird things you can do
with syntax that are just syntactic so
there is a divorce even within the kind
of architectural framework and so it's
not too surprising that you also find
that divorce at the neuropsychological
level I would say
well that I I think I I would I would
want a prediction of the language is
thought evolutionary idea then right so
like uh if that's not if you're saying
that that doesn't predict that thought
is relies on language
um then then uh I think Whoever likes
that theory should should come up with
some predictions
um about uh you know what that what that
theory actually means I mean I feel like
those kinds of predictions are are often
really necessary for understanding the
the content of a prediction
um
um so sorry Daniel your your hand's been
been up for a while uh no it's all good
just kind of wanted to
bring a
um breath in and um an opportunity for
anyone to uh ask any other
questions but wow
thank you both for the many topics we've
covered
um
we'll have in the last minutes uh kind
of conclusion and next steps but Dave
would you like to ask a question or just
give a short reflection
okay no
um
there are many comments in the chat so I
hope that both of you can read them on
your own time to to see what everyone
added
where do we go from here as we
Roar into May 2023 and Beyond
what can linguists large language model
developers and users cognitive
scientists what do you each think are
some of the most fruitful Pathways
forward
okay
I would say um you know uh the most
fruitful pathway forward is to really
take
um like cognitive psychology no
seriously there's a lot of nice work
recently trying to align things like
yeah you know Church EBT wolf from alpha
plugins the way that chat gbt can
interface with different kind of modules
um the way of building a legitimate kind
of AGI system it doesn't necessarily
have to you know be psychologically
reliant on the kind of modules that
human beings have but I think it will
benefit from it so there have been some
some claims that large language models
can maybe do you know all sorts of
things right everything everything you
like
um but I think in the long run it's most
likely going to be the case that llms
can do something very important and very
interesting but it's only going to be
one piece of the puzzle so in fact even
open AI CEO Sam Altman said last week
that
um you know what we can do with llms has
really kind of been exhausted we need
new directions new new new avenues and
so on I guess it was probably you know
speaking to investors more than uh you
know linguistic students here but I
think he's also right you know llms can
do something spectacular but they're
probably going to form a small part of
the general AGI architecture right and
if you want to think about AGI as a
potential potential goal here
um so you know I think a lot of the so
let me give me another example here so
um Anna even over
um who's a a very good productive
scientist she has a paper recently
um arguing for a kind of modular
architecture for llms and which is a
very nice framework right it's very
cognitively plausible it's exactly the
kind of thing that we should be pushing
for it's compatible with Howard
Gardner's you know notion of multiple
intelligences and so on
um but I think at the same time just
just to finish this comment
um there was a tech talk last week I
think or maybe a few days ago where um a
lot of other stuff can be conflated with
AI hype in unproductive ways so Greg
Brockman from openai he gave one of his
uh one of these big Ted Talks where he
showed different plugins that chat GPD
can do I mentioned Wolfram operate but
there's also things like image
generation instacart shopping where you
can get chat TV to buy you things and
what have you
um and again this this takes you back to
the idea that multiple subsystems can do
different sub functions so Brockovich
also showed an example of giving chat
GPT an Excel file a CSV file and from an
archive database of academic papers
where it just listed a bunch of papers
and and then titles and what have you
right
um and he said that you know using
chatipati it uses World Knowledge to
infer what the titles of the columns
mean so we understood that you know
title means the title of the paper it
understood that authors mean the number
of authors per paper it understood that
created means the date that paper
submitted right and because it's a TED
talk you know the whole the audience
gave us a standing ovation right
um but the ability to describe labels on
an Excel file
is I guess nice but um I'm not sure
you'd really call it World Knowledge so
I guess there's a lot I would just say
there's a lot of progress needs to be
made alongside reducing anthropomosome
and you have the right balance of it so
like I said you have to have the right
balance of
um psychologically plausible kind of
modular architecture but you can't have
too much
um anthropomorphism because then you'll
get carried away you have to find we
have to find the right balance between
modeling kind of human-like uh modular
systems but not doing it to a degree
that is a bit you know
um implausible or scientifically
unhelpful
I mean I think I I agree with all that
I'm really excited about these uh ways
of kind of connecting language models to
uh other forms of of information
processing uh which does seem like what
what people have I think I've I mean
I've been like very surprised at the uh
the things they are able to do
um just as as language modeling right so
um you know different kinds of reasoning
puzzles and things that they can solve I
I think is is uh really fascinating and
and you know maybe will require us to to
rethink our you know the the
relationships between language and
thought and and try to figure out a way
of being specific about what it means
for something to uh have a
representation or to reason over that
that representation But ultimately I
think I I agree that um
um you know people have different modes
of thinking about things and that that
seems important for uh for intelligence
um I'm also super excited about the baby
LM challenge so I think on the kind of
linguistic side right
um uh that's exactly the the right thing
of of seeing how far we can get with uh
smaller data sets um and maybe
eventually after that you know trying to
um uh understand some some more about
the kinds of semantics that that kids
acquire and and where they get it from
and and how kind of external semantics
can inform uh language learning or
specifically maybe maybe grammar and and
syntax learning
um I guess my my other uh path forward
point would would be
um that there's uh like I I feel like
these kinds of models have have
um uh really gone far beyond people's
expectations for this kind of class of
of model right kind of ground up
statistical learning discovering
patterns in in text
um
um seems Seems to give like really
pretty remarkable results
um and that for me going forward I I
think has just introduced a huge wave of
uncertainty over theories so I think
that our theories of basically
everything in language for sure
um but cognition probably Neuroscience
right like all of those things I think
are are going to be reworked when we
when we really come to kind of
understand the
um uh the ability of really General
kinds of learning systems like these so
um that makes it you know on the one
hand uh
um kind of a bummer for for past
theories right especially theories which
relied on on
um uh you know learning not being able
to to work well
um but on the upside I think it it makes
it a a very exciting time both for for
AI and cognitive science and and
Linguistics
um where now there's these these really
really powerful tools
um that that seem like a qualitatively
uh different size step towards human
human abilities
um and I think kind of integrating them
and and taking uh both the the kind of
engineering lessons and the the kind of
philosophical lessons about how they're
made and and what kinds of principles go
into designing intelligent systems I
think that that uh those things will
will really shape the feel over the next
five or ten years
um
and also like I would just say in in the
context of broader themes here right
like you're totally right like I
remember when I was reading about when
deep blue be uh Casper of was it the the
chess uh thing right yeah and there were
some commentators who said you know
chess is over if an AI can be a human
then it's game over what's the point in
studying chess you know there's no need
of boring anymore
um and I guess if AI has achieved
seemingly everything that humans need to
do to play chess what's the point of
playing it
um but I think you know if anything it
turned out to increase the popularity of
Chess right they're in our mini chess
celebrities as well worldwide
tournaments and I I would predict that
the same is probably gonna happen with
language too you know llms do not mean
it's the end of language no more
language no more Linguistics I would
actually push back and say maybe it
would be the opposite
um you know the success of LMS will
increase general interest in linguistic
Theory due to their pairing you know
weird constraints and and apparent
limitations right because I would also
say you know scale at this point the the
stress issue scale is kind of definitely
far from all that's needed what is
lacking is an ability of LMS to you know
really abstract their knowledge and
experiences in order to make group wash
predictions and generalizations and so
on I gave some examples but there's some
others in the literature where it
doesn't seem to really be good at
generalizing it can go of maybe
particular token types and but I would
you know I would guess my final my final
claim would be that you know the
language acquisition literature
um doesn't necessarily need llms though
you know cognitive scientists don't
really need llms we could potentially uh
you know reinstate and obviously
disagree here but um I would say big
tech companies profiting off llms need
llms right they're the only ones that
really do it may be the case that the
mind is a very I will say you know the
mind is a very diverse space it may be
that there are certain forms of behavior
and learning that might be captured by
processes similar to what llms are doing
so Stephen has given some interesting
examples in his papers about magnetism
and and weird kind of rules of learning
that are very domain General and very
quick and very mysterious so you know
maybe for those sorts of things that
that kind of learning will be will be
relevant and but I still think it's
unlikely that one of the candidates will
be natural language and at least the way
natural language works and it's full
glory in terms of the form mainly
regulation and what have you so I guess
I would you know it kind of reminds me
of where you you know you have this
image of I saw John Wick chapter four
recently right and he has this there's
this scene where he's walking in the
desert and he's not sure if he's seen
this guy like he wants to assassinate
it's kind of like when you walk in the
desert
um and you have an illusion of seeing an
oasis because it turns out you're
hallucinating but then you realize that
you know sometimes before it's too late
that you actually are hallucinating it's
you're not seeing an oasis you're still
in the desert and I think that's kind of
maybe the situation we're in right now
with with linguistic competence of lots
of language models we have the illusion
of uh linguistic competence for you know
um you always see the illusion before
you find the Oasis right so I think I
think right now we're in the
hallucinating state of the desert where
we're seeing potential Sparks of of
linguistic competence but it's still not
very clear and robust
um we haven't actually reached the Oasis
yet yeah
um just a rapid fire question so see if
you can give a a short response so
svenochino
writes question is it correct to say
that large language models have no
priors
do large language models have priors I'd
say yes they definitely do
um and
um they're I think the the difference to
how people you know are used to thinking
about priors and in Bayesian inference
for example if you like write down a
Bayesian statistical model you you say
like you know here's the parameters and
here's what the priors are on the
parameters
um large language models I think the the
priors are and maybe neural nuts in
general I think that the that the the
priors are much more implicit right so
there's some functions which they find
easier to learn than uh than other
functions and there's even some work
trying to discover you know some
statement of what those kind of implicit
priors are
um but that that's actually how I think
about
um
um you know comparison of different
neural network architectures right
um uh which is maybe something elated
and I might might agree on right like
you have to find priors which allow them
to learn the things that that kids learn
right and
um not all architectures will do that
um even among architectures which are
turning complete or capable of learning
any kind of function not all of them
will will do it uh even on on kind of
huge data set sizes so
um I I think of this sort of search over
neural net architectures as really one
of of a search over priors
um but it's not priors or I mean you
could think of it as a search over
Universal grammar or something right but
it's it's it's not priors or Universal
grammar in the sense that people have
talked about it as like an explicit
statement about what kinds of rules are
allowed or an explicit statement about
what kinds of functions are high
probability or something like that it's
all implicitly coded there
um yeah yeah totally I think I think
that's right I mean you know the real
question is reducing the space of what
those that prize alike and if it's
anything remotely like what human beings
are doing so llm's like I would I would
at least say that things like qpt3 are
in existence proof of you know that
building fully functioning syntactic
categories from surface distributional
analysis this alone is possible that's
yes that is correct but you know even so
I would say most practitioners don't
really believe that syntactic categories
are innate so the prior issue is
slightly less irrelevant here it's the
operations that are set to be innate so
the in the syntax domain it's particular
linguistic computations that are said to
be in a and categories themselves in
fact even Charles Yang
um has admitted in the last couple years
that they are maybe in it but maybe not
so people have given another of a
relevant priority are things like
um you know me and Gary markets have
talked about compositionality that seems
to be a big problem so people have given
chat gbt BBC News articles asking it to
compress it and then re-explain it uh so
one example I saw was Peter Smith 58 is
being arrested on charges of
manslaughter and you get it to compress
it and re-explain it and it comes out as
58 people are being charged with
manslaughter right that's a pretty clear
example of a lack of compositionality
being built into whatever compression
it's doing and there's another example
where there's been there's some examples
of potential analogical reasoning so in
Bing chat you know Bing has this this
trap function
um the question is is it just finding
meta relations that have already been
documented by humans or is it genuinely
creating new relations the new stuff
that's being built
um so you know someone asked uh drew me
a table comparing Jesus Christ with the
Nokia 9910 right the cell phone Nokia
um and it said you know they compared
the release dates it compared the size
the weight it compared the CPU with
Jesus's all-powerful knowledge it
compared the memory of the phone with
the all-knowing nature of God right
um also I think it said that they were
both resurrected because the Nokia was
re-released a couple of times right so
the Nokia sounds like a great answer
what's wrong with that that's okay it
may be maybe it sounds a lot like
analogical reasoning but then it also
had some quite weird ones where it was
like you know for the camera it said no
it just gave Jesus's description or it's
not really what a camera is there's some
kind of things that look like analogical
reasoning maybe but it's unclear yeah
hey I think that that sounds like an
awesome answer to me
I I was going to say like you you said
large language models learn their
existence proof of part of speech
categories but like they don't just
output part of speech categories right
like they they have a lot of grammatical
syntactic knowledge
um uh and moreover like they have a lot
of semantic knowledge and probably some
pragmatic knowledge and you know they're
they're not bad at translation and like
it's it's way more that they have
discovered
um than just part of speech categories
um uh well I'm sorry I said I'm sorry
it's a technical categories
right yeah well sorry so yeah yeah but
they've discovered way more than that
um
yeah um
I'm going to as a um teaser slash
motivator for hopefully both of you to
join uh again in the future with or
without other guests a few of the
exciting questions just for us to
include in this transcript and then
thank you both Ellie and Steven for
joining so just a few of the last
questions that were asked Juan asked how
do small Transformers Jang at all 2020
compared with children learning language
um 96 asked what are your thoughts on
implicit priors versus animal Instinct
rojda asked what constraints that space
in llms don't they get there by training
so are they discovering it that's not
what they Implement at the start maybe
and there's many more questions so I
hope that we can all um review and
re-read each other's works and come
together for 41.2 in some future time
thank you Elliot and Steven for this
excellent stream thank you Dave thank
you both yeah thank you so much
farewell bye see you